[Music]
20:19 was an incredible year for g2 but
with the summoner's Cup still missing
from their trophy cabinet the team has
turned to young and promising ad carry
selves as in the spring to see if he can
turn their fortunes around if they
actually do win this spring split with a
rural swap that just actually destroys
the confidence of all the other teams
even more it's like you can't even beat
when they were also like what chance do
you have you ever player role swapping
it's the same five players statistically
you guys are just worse now admittedly
when we track week before last season we
were eight zero right and you're 62 now
so we'll give you the benefit of doubt
but you're just slightly worse in every
metric and I think that our role swap
which remember happened because we
wanted to have fun and I think we're
having a very good fun
is it working just fine taps with a
pentakill to persuade the naysayers
there's one down as reckless fools
nemesis trying to run away as well the
perks is just shredding through them he
listens gonna get the passive out of
wonder but that's not gonna be enough as
he pulls as well three kills the nail in
favor of g2 g2 are inevitable g2 are
inescapable Europe g2 ah your spring
split champions g2 eSports are the best
european league team ever in 2019 they
won both LEC splits made it to the
finals of the World Championships and
became the first EU team to win MSI
from Europe a world record g2 eSports
3-0 will win MSI 2019
but in order for this team to come
together perks took a huge risk role
swapping to ad carry a risk that
resulted in him becoming one of the
world's best ad carry's revolutionising
the bot lane meta in the process I think
that whenever the pressure reaches its
peak he is the player that matches that
pressure and overcomes it and here all
swapped and went from being an ad carry
player that no one had any expectations
for into becoming the best day to carry
domestically this guy has redefined how
the role has played so after finding all
of that success last year you'd think
that the MSI champions and world
finalists would simply just run it back
but G choose to Kerry's role swapped
again Perks return to the mid lane where
he's dominated for most of his career
while caps well he made the jump into
the world of ad carry's why do you want
to Walton weight and you want to commit
late uh yeah I mean I think I could yeah
nothing I could compare what line okay
well then why I'm actually this I think
we are what's the worst that can happen
[Music]
in addition to the potential benefits of
both players mastering two lanes the
Ross swap gave the team something to
meme on I think that our role swap which
remember happened because we wanted to
have fun and I think we're having a very
good fun is is working just fine well
perks easily returned to his old star
midlaner form caps wasn't so quick to
adapt sometimes he'd look great crushing
it with Santa other times he'd go oh in
nine on affiliates
as misfits are looking to take down the
undefeated Massacre with Holland virgins
fabbi going forward the head comes away
already one is sure jeetu were still at
the top of the regular season standings
but compared to summer they just didn't
look as dominant as they used to
statistically you guys are just worse
now admittedly when we track week before
last season we were eight zero right and
you're 62 now so we'll give you the
benefit of doubt but you're just
slightly worse in every metric in with
pork's balling out amid fans is worries
focused on caps worries that became a
reality come the playoffs cap Sonique
you can't stall this out maybe with the
megaphone a poem but maybe the bottles
the rookies have risen up the defending
champions and g2 eSports are on the back
legs there's no waste
there's no way spiders are down they've
done it it's that mad lions they have
unseated the champions they have killed
the Kings the rookies of Europe have
taken down the world finalists and the
two-time 2019 champions mad Lions have
earned this victory mad Lions have
defeated g2 I think it's it really is to
say that G to underperform in comparison
to what they did the regular splits
because like everyone's on the
capsule-like bandwagon hate now but
throughout the regular season he didn't
ever play this bad like it was it was
absurd how many times past 10 minutes
and he got caught in mids when his only
job was to clear waves with something
like zigs caps on the rest of the g2
roster were sent to the loser's bracket
by man Lyons a roster made up of four
rookies and it turned out to be a major
wake-up call if we can't even beat met
than that we have no chance against the
rest
so we just you know make sure that we
add a much higher level this fit will
not be won easily like even now we still
have to win tuber survives and leg back
to back in within two days but I believe
we can do it because we want to do it
and we will put in the work to to just
become so much better than that wake-up
call was all they needed because in
their losers bracket
run caps and g2 is a squad looked very
different
they finished the Bantam stir before
done to upset almost takes them out
posters in an upset is down called out
by caps who dived in from the side and
that's a double four caps he's looking
for three he's looking for more he's
looking for for its new tuck gets
exhausted and will fall there's the
triple destiny next on the menu for the
Quadra kill four caps secures it was
going for the Penta wuji to steal it
away from him because I Bobby is trading
but the chains locks up Bobby in place
caps with a pentakill to s way that the
naysayers no one thought he could play
well last week well offensive puts them
in that place heading into the fourth
consecutive domestic file
g2 were up against their longtime rivals
with fnatic four caps this was his
biggest challenge as Navy carry yet not
only were fnatic G choose biggest
competition they also had the league's
best ad carry in reckless
luckily for g2 caps had a plan
holy moly they're like okay we've gone
through robbing shots we've gone through
the pregame let's get on into this match
in the Matic unwilling to give up on
this fight as they have been do the
entire spread Mickey's gonna flash away
just about manages to survive perks on
his way up as well has yet to join this
fight those suits are still in from the
side it's a quick famine from g2 I don't
know if fanatical gonna get there in
time because only a thousand HP left on
it and now it's gone the court of
fortune or coming out fnatic have to
look to try and take this fight because
g2 if they get out alive they can just
push through the sidelines selfies
already dead yet coach takes him and now
Matt just trying to open up he's been
caught in pacifism
devoured up I'm a hell of Sam but you
have to watch reckless as he is spat out
its wall of Jeter ooh
for vanilla in favor of g2 they are
demolishing fnatic in these fights
fnatic they funnel into the band pit
thinking that they could finally get a
one team five verses to youtube but we
saw artillery tank caps that man did not
move and he was just spitting out all
the damage onto the entire fnatic liner
g2 are inevitable g2 are inescapable
Europe g2 are your spring split
champions as they take down the Nexus
and claim in the end their seventh title
matching the record set by fnatic seven
titles for g2 not only had caps found
the perfect counter to fanatics
predictable drafting his team fighting
got dramatically better the Orang Altima
doesn't connect and then blip of flashes
and then tries to find the knock up on
caps and caps is like Nami and that
teamfight he like takes like a slight
sidestep he's like out putting all his
DPS he's or walking beautifully like he
I understand the people like he just sat
down and like one teamfight that was
just like the one that was like yeah
that a series really well earning their
third consecutive domestic title g2
proved that this experiment was a
success and despite some of the missteps
along the way it made them stronger g2
is by far and beyond super far ahead of
everyone into v2 mid gonca sparks have a
lot of history together and they figure
out their early game issue last year
there was no early game room due to most
of the time it was like we do we kind of
give the enemy a 3k gold lead we give
them hope and then at 10 minutes we
smack you up now they smack you up for a
minute - fantastic but for fans of caps
as an ad carry I got some bad news for
you
come this summer perks and caps are
going back to their 2019 rolls why you
might ask
especially after they just won another
domestic title caps doesn't like playing
ad carry swapping perps back to them to
ad and caps it doesn't change the fact
that improves the team and basically the
main reason also why we do it
that's because caps
like pokes of the last year this unhappy
playing button well they might be
returning to their old roles the skills
they've learned through this spring
experiment will carry over to this new
roster basically what we mean by saying
this is a better team it's not about how
the players individually fill the roles
is about how we the team identified
mistakes no game plan in the game and as
for g2 they just got a whole lot scarier
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this hit the sub button and
ring that notification bell for unique
bite-sized videos you will find anywhere
else hit up our Instagram Twitter and
Facebook pages
[Music]
you